new in theaters this weekend frozen to a
beautiful day in the neighborhood and 21
bridges what will you see this is your
weekend ticket always fee opposes powers
were too much for this world frozen to
takes place three years after the first
frozen and Elsa has been hearing a call
to travel north that she can no longer
resist so she along with her sister Anna
Kristoff and Olaf and Sven set off on an
adventure to seemingly discover the
origins of her powers the full story has
been appropriately shrouded in mystery
with the trailers only hinting at what's
to come and Olaf himself Josh GAD
tweeted begging moviegoers to keep story
elements and spoilers secret so it looks
like you're gonna have to go see it to
find out what will happen in arendelle
and beyond this movie is for you if
you're looking for a movie for the whole
family this weekend you can't wait to
see how the story continues or you're a
parent excited that a new movie will
replace seeing frozen one on repeat I
see you parents for doing an issue on
inspirational people Oh
mr. Rogers hello television so good to
see you again today you hired me as an
investigative journalist at under puff
pieces 400 words a beautiful day in the
neighborhood centers on a journalist who
is reluctant to do an assigned piece on
mr. Rogers but through his time with the
children's TV show host he learns the
true nature of the man his impact and
message and he even learned something
about himself this movies for you if
you're looking for a feel-good movie
this weekend you're excited to see Tom
Hanks play the lovable man or you don't
trust your neighbors and are hoping
you'll get some Intel from the movie
they'll help protect you because they're
definitely up to something I mean you
can hear them at night tinkering their
whispers it's definitely about you I
know too much they know where you live
and they must be stopped at all oh wait
they might watch this show now your
neighbors are cool right
be afraid to shoot us
we have training so he does not bear the
sword in vain that will fund and they
heated pursuit of two cop killers all 21
bridges in and out of Manhattan are
closed off and the chase begins as crazy
things start to become uncovered this
movie is produced by the Russo brothers
so there's bound to be some intense
action and maybe Thanos this movies for
you if an action drama is what you seek
you look forward to seeing black
panthers chadwick boseman again or you
love bridges I just wish Jeff Bridges
was in the movie for you too but
whatever would have been 22 bridges then
that is your weekend ticket will you see
and check back next week for a whodunit
by Rian Johnson